hallo mein Name ist Luk meine Damen und
Herren ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen endlich mal
wieder zu einer neuen Episode ebay fails
ich le mich ansatzweise so episch wie
dieses Intro jetzt denn wir starten
direkt mit diesem Gefäß was hier auf
eBay verkauft wird das sieht so ein
bisschen aus wie diese Wunderlampe von
Aladdin
oder auf plus 18 Webseiten auch gern
analdien genannt so oder so wird diese
Wunderlampe auf Ebay reingestellt als
allerdings
Wunderlampe also die Abwandlung von
Aladdin kannte ich jetzt auch noch nicht
hier wurden zwei Tennisschläger auf eBay
Kleinanzeigen eingestellt die Person hat
allerdings das T mit dem D verwechselt
und die ganzen Sachen dennischläger
getauft ich würde dir was empfehlen
Sprachen lnen Babbel hier verkauft
jemand eine jesusgrippe aka Jesus
Grippe ich
meine vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur
ein veranschaulich unds Foto und die
Person verkauft wirklich die Grippe von
Jesus falls er dann mal krank
war wenn Jesus krank war hat er dann
Gott einfach angerufen hat so gesagt
Bruder mach mich mal gesund so ich habe
ein bisschen was zu tun auf der Erde was
bisschen wichtiger isten hier wird ein
Schlagzeug verkauft die Person nennt das
ganze allerdings Schlag
Eugen
also sollen wir jetzt Eugen schlagen
od hier verkauft jemand das PlayStation
3 Spiel Call of Duty und nennt das ganze
call of
booty ich liebe Spiele und welches spiel
ich in letzter Zeit besonders mag ist
das neue monopoli go dort erwartet euch
nämlich eine neue Interpretation des
beliebten Brettspiels und ich als alter
monopolly og Fan und
selbstverständlich auch Profi findet das
natürlich höchst interessant bei
Monopoly go findet ihr viele klassische
Elemente wie das würfeln und die
Spielfiguren wieder jedoch auch ganz
neue Features und innovative
Spielelemente das Spiel ist einfach
generell super geeignet um es in
verschiedenen challenges und Minigames
mit euren Freunden zu spielen und eines
davon ist das neue Coop Event
spielzeugpartner bei dem ihr bis zum 7
Oktober mit euren Freunden gemeinsam
zusammenarbeiten könt um Belohnungen und
Meilensteine zu verdienen das Spiel geht
gerade übrigens ziemlich viral und das
eines der beliebtesten in den AppStores
also ladet euch ganz ganz schnell runter
über den Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung oder über den QR-Code
den ihr hier auch schon die ganze Zeit
eingeblendet seht viel Spaß schieben
Monopoly go jetzt allerdings beiseite
meine Damen und Herren machen weiter mit
den ebay fails und zwar einem
Autogramm was hier verkauft wird und man
sieht ja schon es ist anscheinend von
einem Dortmund Spieler mir wird da als
allererstes Matz Hummels einfallen es
ist tatsächlich auch von
allerdings kannte die Person den Namen
von ihm wohl nicht so richtig und
schreibt einfach Matz
Humus Bro Humus ist kein Spieler das ist
Essen hier werden drei Dinosaurier
verschenkt die dann allerdings nicht
drei Dinosaurier genannt werden in dem
Titel des Beitrags sondern dinosauer
Dreier hier haben wir ein sitzendes
Erdmännchen was von dem Verkäufer
allerdings
erdogänchen annt
wird
Bro wie am Arsch können diese Leute
eigentlich sein ein
Fuchs sag
mal hackt's bei euch hier verkauft
jemand Kacke gefuttert Größe 80 und man
denkt sich jetzt vielleicht gefutterte
Kacke vielleicht hat jemand seine Kacke
gefüttert und Größe 80 ist vielleicht 80
kg oder 80 cm keine Ahnung es wird ja
auch oft als Dünger verwendet er
verkauft allerdings eine
Jacke eine gefütterte Jacke und keine
gefutterte Kacke das hier ist auch sehr
stark wir haben natürlich mal wieder
Jesus hier das ist auch irgendwie eine
sehr religiöse Folge
bisher auf jeden Fall wird halt eine
Holzfigur von Jesus verkauft die
allerdings holzfick von Zeus genannt
wird in Klammern alte Mann what the
fucker also wer hat die Leute hier
verarscht hier verkauft jemand die Gucci
northf Collabo Jacke die
höchstwahrscheinlich Fake ist er weiß
nämlich nicht wie das Ganze heißt und
schreibt gug
Jacke Jacke mit Y na lasst euch nicht
verarschen seid ihr da auf Ebay seid
könnt ihr auch einfach D rein stecken
mich zu Abonnieren hat man mehr von ist
sogar kostenlos Klick unter dem Video
auf abonnieren oder eure Ärmel rutschen
runter beim Hände waschen xD Und hier
meine Damen und Herren verkauft beim
nächsten ebayfil jemand seinen Ring 120
€ denn sie hat nein gesagt und ich weiß
auch nicht woran das eventuell hätte
liegen können es ist halt ein
wunderschöner Ring für eine
Hochzeit mit dem nächsten EBF kann ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz viel
anfangen denn ihr wisst ich hasse Kaffee
ich liebe Tee aber ich hasse Kaffee ich
liebe aber den Geruch von Kaffee den
Geruch aus so einer frisch gemalenen
Kaffeemühle wenn er diese Bohnen gemalen
wur das ist schon super und sowas wird
tatsächlich hier auf ebay auch gerade
verkauft das hier nämlich sieht auch
noch ganz schön aus das Problem ist
allerdings dass er das ganze als
kaffenmüll
betitelt na ja hier wird eine DVD
verkauft von dem unglaublichen HK im
Titel steht allerdings der unglaubliche
haarealt ich frag mich gar nichts mehr
hier haben wir tatsächlich wieder ein
Autogramm bzw eine Autogrammkarte von
Tony Koss einem deutschen
Fußballnationalspieler jedoch wusste
auch die Person hier nicht den Namen vom
Spieler und schreib daraufhin signierte
Autogrammkarte von Toningenieur
Cross Toningenieur ich mE vielleicht ist
er das nebenberuflich verdient bei Real
Madrid glaube ich nicht so gut hier
verkauft jemand einen käsehobler aka
Käse
Holger ich weiß ehlich gesagt auch gar
nicht mehr was ich dazu sagen soll hier
werden Damenhosen verkauft der Verkäufer
nennt die ganzen Dinger allerdings
sieben Stück
damenhoden
Bro das hier ist eine Powerbank die auf
Ebay kleinerzeigen reingestellt wurde
und ich verstehe nicht was so schwer
daran ist das Ding auch einfach
Powerbank zu betiteln die Person
schreibt aber Power Frank ey ich könnte
wirklich hier so ein kotzeimer nebenes
Video stellen hier hat jemand eine Tommy
Hilfiger Jacke eingestellt und will
diese Jacke auch verkaufen auf eBay dann
nenn die Jacke doch auch Tommy Hilfiger
Jacke und nicht Tommy hilf Lehrer was
ist ein Hilfslehrer hier verkauft jemand
einen Nintendo Switch Donkey Kong
Controller Bro es heißt Controller und
Donkey Kong und nicht Switch controlleur
Dinkel Kong was ist der controlleur
Dinkel Kong ein selfie
ST
Stab ich Kön kotzen springbur bet Bro es
heißt boxpringbett hier wird Gary die
Schnecke verkauft das schneckenhaustier
von Spongebob es heißt Gary und nicht
Garet Garret die schne ich ich kotze in
dein Arsch das hier ist ein saug und
Wischroboter der nichts mit Saufen zu
tun hat saugen nicht
saufen ich pack das nicht mehr der weiße
Heiner ich bin so kurz vom
Nervenzusammenbruch ne wir machen noch
einen allerletzten
fail das
hier ein Angry Bird
Stofftier Angry Birds Angry Birds ist
Englisch für wütende
Vögel wirklich danke an Monopoly go dass
sie das heutige Video supportet und
finanziell unterstützt haben aber ich
pack's nicht mehr ich spiele jetzt
Monopoly go ich habe keinen Bock mehr
auf diese ebay fils